-If you need
to laugh this weekend,
tune in to SNL.
It is going remote.
-"Saturday Night Live" returns
with an all-new episode
from home.
-It's gonna be so fascinating
to see them
in their element at home.
-I can't wait to see
how they pull that off.
-Initially, I was like,
"Oh, man!
This is gonna suck!"
[ Laughing ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-I'm Daniel Craig.
This has been
"Saturday Night Live."
Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
-That last show...
[ Rewinding ]
it didn't feel like
we wouldn't be coming back.
There was no indication
that that would kind of be
our live show season finale.
-I think I got an email
that was just sent to everybody
and they were like, "Hey,
we're gonna do it at home now."
-I remember being
a little perplexed
as to how we would do it.
-"SNL" is so much chaos.
The one sort of grounding force
we have is the audience.
-We do a multicam
live sketch show.
So the we feed off
of the studio audience.
-The suspect, described
as a white male --
-Whew!
-Love it!
[ Laughter ]
-The show's always been at 8H.
We've always done it at 30 Rock.
-But, if everyone else is in,
I'm in and, I mean, I'm excited
'cause what else am I doing?
I'm home.
-This equipment would arrive
at our house.
We'd be like, "What is this?
I guess there's a sketch
involving a greenscreen."
So, now, we have a greenscreen,
-For the first show.
we did a Zoom table read.
-I hope you guys enjoy
our table read here
and we'll see what we
come up with on Saturday.
This is crazy.
-And one of the sketches
we read at the table
was the dating show.
-Hello and welcome
to "How Low Will You Go?"
-The most surreal moment --
there was a dating show.
I got up and stood on the side
of my little computer area,
waiting for my cue as they were
doing the sketch on Zoom
and it feels kind of like
the normal show.
You're waiting for your cue.
-Hello-o-o, ladies!
-I just remember having
a distinct moment,
thinking like,
"I will remember this forever."
-You're setting up a ring light
and a greenscreen
and all these things
that you don't usually do.
So, then, by the time
you're shooting the thing,
you're just overwhelmed.
-It was also crazy because,
our first show back,
Hal Willner died.
I just like can't picture
working on a sketch
without talking to him.
It was very difficult.
-This was challenging.
-It was hard,
but we were in it together,
and that was really nice.
-For the SoulCycle sketch,
my next door neighbors
yelled lines
in response to my lines.
-It's crazy to think that people
could be watching this
anywhere from Los Angeles
to California.
-[ Laughs ]
I heard my neighbor say,
"Los Angeles is in California."
Like they didn't get that
I was shooting a sketch.
[ Knocking ]
I knocked on their door.
I was just like,
"We're shooting this thing."
I apologize.
It won't happen again.
But maybe it will happen
again in two weeks."
The first thing I did was
I did the Drake song
and the Andre 2000 song.
It was super weird.
We would go outside and dance
in the middle of the street
and then like
my neighbor would come
and get like his mail
and just like look up.
And I'd be like,
[ Laughing ] "SNL at Home."
-♪ I'm stuck in the core ♪
♪ Got nothin' to do ♪
-I had this other song
that I was workin' on,
that I just, on a whim,
sent to Sandler
and he ended up liking it
and then he was just like,
"I'm gonna do a verse on this,"
and I was like, "Holy [bleep]
This is crazy."
♪ I'm so [bleep] bored,
I'm doin' songs with me ♪
♪ Stuck with my fam,
I can't get out ♪
-And that is, by far,
my favorite like SNL moment
like that I've ever had,
for sure.
-♪ And crazy ♪
-It got better
as the weeks went on.
-Paul?
-Mandy?
-Yeah! Mandy!
-I guess, slowly, things just
stopped being as overwhelming.
-And then, the second one,
you know,
we cranked it up a notch
because, now, we had time
to send wigs out,
and send costumes
and it was obvious
in that second episode.
-I guess one of the best parts
was how our families
got involved.
My seven-year-old son,
he would be
in our read-throughs.
-[ Indistinct ]
-It's hard on them, too.
-Like this bitch knows anything.
[ Laughter ]
-We worked on this dad
prank sketch.
-So I have a...
[ Electronic voice ]
-Brandon!
-[ Electronic voice ]
-I wrote him a thank you.
Right now, it's just
kind of annoying
to have to go up
and shoot and stuff, but,
when you're older, I think
you'll think it's pretty cool
that you got to be a part
of this show.
-Watchin' my daughter
watch herself
in my intro on the show,
she was just beaming.
She just couldn't stop smiling,
that, I mean, I could've
cried, watchin' that.
Can you say bye-bye?
-Bye-bye.
-Bye-bye!
To see what you do immediately
impact your child like that,
that was a very touching moment.
-At-home episodes
sort of felt like
we got a job to do here
and it just sort of felt
like an experimental thing.
-Especially when Brad Pitt
said it, like "Live..."
-...kinda,
from all across America,
it's Saturday night.
It's like, "Okay,
we're gettin' a glimpse
into an invincibility
with the show."
Like whether we do it
at 30 Rock or not,
I think we can figure out a way
to get it done.
-For the "Dreams" sketch,
I didn't know what
everyone else was doing.
-I had been reading an article
about COVID dreams
and how intense
they were for people
and I'd had some myself,
so I started to think
like what would it be like
to see the dreams of the cast,
what they miss and, you know,
maybe what we all
sort of miss about New York?
-The director, Paul Briganti,
directed over Zoom.
-Alright.
And action.
-We did like
a read-through of it.
After we finished reading it,
all of us just looked
at each other's
little tiles on Zoom
and we were like silent.
And then I remember breaking
the silence by being like...
I hope everyone
has a good summer.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
-Seeing the city and us being
digitally put into the city
was kinda bittersweet and sad,
but, at the same time,
uplifting,
seeing us all together again.
-I guess we just never thought
that we would get to a point
where we wouldn't be able
to have New York.
Walk in Times Square,
be bumped into on Fifth Avenue,
or any of that.
It was very emotional.
-Those shows were
a nice reminder
that this is still possible,
that it was still possible
to sort of be there
for each other,
even though we were so separate.
-Getting to watch that episode
from the comfort of my home
in New York made me feel
so connected to the city.
-Coming off the elevator
Saturday night
and seeing a neighbor
who was like,
"Are you gonna watch your show?"
[ Laughing ]
I was like,
"Yeah.
Are you gonna watch it?"
-I'm waiting for us to be able
to get back in 30 Rock.
Oh, man. I wish I could get
a good night's hug right now.
-I can't wait to go back.
I can't wait to go back
and see everybody.
-I'm really like grateful
that we had those three shows.
I won't forget
and I'm like appreciative
to have been part of it.
-Yay! That was great.
-Yay!
[ Laughter ]
[ Static crackles ]
-What I wanna say is
we'll get through
this thing together,
but we'll also come
out on the other side
with a little more compassion
and appreciation
for our world
that we live in, you know?
Show some more love
to each other,
show some more
love to our planet.
That's all I can hope for.